protesters run for their lives a number
of people were killed here in this pnom
Penn suburb as government troops opened
fire in an effort to break up labor
protests many were wounded in the
crackdown the soldiers should be
protecting the sovereignty of the
country so I am wondering why they are
protecting this factory instead more
than half of the country's estimated
650,000 garment workers have gone on
strike many work for popular Western
brands like added ass Nike or H&M
conditions at the factories here maybe
better than in Bangladesh but wages are
low just around 60 euros a month barely
enough to put food on the table workers
are demanding double that rate but the
government led by Prime Minister Hun Sen
has only offered a 25 percent increase
but the strikes pose a threat to Hun
Sen's nearly three decades rule the
garment industry is Cambodia's biggest
export earner and the protests are some
of the largest Cambodia has ever seen
the protesters are also backed by the
opposition they accuse Hansen of rigging
last year's vote and are calling on him
to step down they say